what do you think's happening to gay
people let's talk about that for a
minute
because it's not fun anymore it's
moralism
i have to tell people how to live it's
very hard for me
to take balls out of my mouth and then
tell people how to live i don't feel
like it's my job
i like going to florida and eating
shrimp but now people want me to go to
libraries and talk to children and
help them realize who they are it's not
my job and i don't care
so what what is this it used to be kind
of fun
and now it's become this really office
politics
bureaucratic uh you know very uh
language driven kind of like it's weird
and strange
and i don't understand it and i don't
like it
it's really sad like whatever is shitty
and cringy
and repressive and weak about liberal
politics
it finds its like lowest point like it's
zenith
in gay institutional politics right
which is really sad because like we're
basically the same age i think you're
like 5 or 10 years older than i am
obviously how old are you
when what how old are you
27 how old are you 16.
so you're wrong yeah so you're right i
stand corrected so like i'm a little
older than you
yes i know you know like when gay
politics
was subversive by necessity harvey mills
radical yes interesting yeah and like
larry kramer
yes andrew sullivan to a degree as well
yeah i mean andrew sullivan was kind of
like ironically the sort of like trying
to be the
catholic conservative you need a
conservative that's why i like
uh caitlyn jenner you need someone you
need someone in the community that just
really likes the country club
yeah well and you also want like
diversity right like that's the whole
point of a liberation movement is not to
be
constrained in captivity but to be free
in your expression of whatever you do
but what it but ultimately like the
politics were more radical and
interesting you know we kind of went
from like larry kramer to [ __ ] pete
budage
right you know that's like for me the
trajectory yes but also
the the what's really happened for me
like in terms of the you know you're
talking about the reversals before on
like foreign policy and imperialism with
rachel maddow and
culture or whatever it's also taken
place culturally
you know when i was growing up the
people who wanted to control private
behavior and culture
was the right you know like jerry
falwell and the moral majority
and like the transgression came from the
left like sinead o'connor ripping up a
picture of the pope
on saturday night live and so the left
always was
the culturally transgressive movement of
liberation that came out of the 60s
obviously as well like the summer of
love right and like hippies and all of
that
the free speech movement as well this is
completely reversed
the cultural left in the united states
has a longer list of rules for how you
can date how you can [ __ ]
how you can like feel sexual attraction
for somebody
than the [ __ ] pope has with his
encyclicals
like all this like formula for who you
can date in ages and like
what you have to do and they want to
control everything everything is abuse
everything is harassment
it is it's like watching this mirror
image
where they have all become this like
highly
repressive movement that
is unrecognizable to me except with
reference to what
the evangelical and christian right was
in the 1980s right